all right Cindy Lou
Cindy Lou where are you from originally
where'd you grow up um I grew up in
Cudahy from 13th till I was 13 from
there I moved to East LA
tell me about your family growing up and
um I stood in East L.A the majority of
my life and uh
I was engaged well actually I was with
this guy for 23 years before that tell
me about your childhood you grew up I
grew up with Mom and Dad
poor no dad
uh he lived in Texas and my mom did the
best she could
and you know we didn't have much means
so it was me and my brothers two
brothers and my little sister she's
seven years apart she has a different
dad
me and my two older brothers we have the
same father
and my mom was in and out of prison no I
love her she maybe she made me the woman
I am today
in spite of my little you know bumps in
the road I guess you could say and
they're my bumps nobody forced me I did
on my own
um
I would describe your childhood in
general
good
no abuse nothing like that no abuse
went to school every day my grandfather
locked us in I had to go to school every
day so yeah you graduate high school no
I did not but I was getting A's all
through High School and I don't know I
just left
you know I needed to Branch out of my I
don't know what my problem was but I
just had to leave at what age what grade
going in the 12th grade
yeah I mean I was making Straight A's in
the 11th grade but yeah
you left to do what
did you go to work
I worked at McDonald's I worked the
graveyard shift
in them
by the time I started drinking
um Sunnybrook
and I was getting too wasted and I guess
that's why I probably left home you know
and um
I did that for a while
um six miles and maybe a little bit long
maybe a year
after that um
I went back home
you opened the doors and stuff and um I
got a job working at a
at an underground uh Boogie Drake
um in the in the races the horses
and I stood there for many many years
this is where I met my kids get Dad
and um
his name is Jess they call him Eddie
preops edx
I I'm Noah my name is Cindy
Cindy Lou my friends call me Lulu
you know
and um
when I met him I uh
I was going out with them for a little
bit and then
we got busted sandwiches house and
we had to
and uh
time goes by so I ended up moving in
with him
so I got pregnant you know the usual
thing you know settle down
you know wanting another kid pop that
one out mother-in-law was mean
you know she didn't like me too much but
what mother-in-law does right
so
after that um
I got my own place I did two bedroom
750.
and I did on my own I still continue to
work
and um
my little sister came
she went back home
anytime just passing just doing the
regular routine work from home feed the
family work come on be the family you
know
but the guy was with was an alcoholic
and we used to fight
I'm talking fight
I never understood why he hit me but he
did
um
and I stood with him for 23 years
it's a long time
um in the course of the 23 years I am
got pregnant
three times
I have three natural births
and I'm
we
we worked you know he worked and came
home gave me the money I went to school
you know regular everything was like no
no no but don't I think was the hitting
part
and then um fast forward
I am 51 today and
um
10 years ago
I left him well 12 years 13 years I left
them
I told you Jimmy one more time and I'm
done
you hit me one more time and I left
um I had lost my daughter because they
said I failed to protect her when he hit
on me
so um
I told you you hit me I'm leaving and I
left
I ended up getting my own place
and I was so lonely
and then um I got my daughter back of
course
and everything was fine I was I was okay
you know for the first time in my life I
felt like
I you know squinched like that or you
know or
somebody's yelling at me or you know you
know it was nice quiet my daughter went
to school every day
did not miss one day
maybe I'm proud of my kids
was 29. graphic design
was 24.
um he's going to school for it all he
had full scholarship paid in full by the
school he was accepted at Ronald Reagan
my daughter
um a veterinarian she worked herself
after school
so I'm proud of my I did a good job you
know just my circumstances you know
so I'm a proud mom for that you know I'm
blessed because I have good kids they're
not in no gangs they're not you know
they want to work you know they want
careers and stuff like that so
me and um their father says it to idiots
two dummies
make three beautiful kids that work that
have you know
we used to put them straight wherever
they wanted to go you know
and um
I was on the internet one night my
daughter was already home I think
I met this guy on the internet
and uh
some girls telling them off no I don't
wanna
talk to you because you're in jail and I
was like you know what screw you girl
because you know never you know that's
just me I felt that that was me
and um so I ended up talking to him
we got along really really good
I ended up getting engaged to him four
and a half years
yep he was in prison the whole time in
prison the whole time
what for murder
and um he was about he was going to go
for his hearing and uh
when all that when he changed prisons
everything changed because
I ended up moving out going to
Victorville
waiting for my settlement because I had
gotten an accident
and um
and things just went
straight down I'm talking rock bottom
and I've been a rock bottom ever since
I'm picking myself up little by little
and I feel good about it
um
where are you staying today
King Edwards hotel and I got the place
on my own by myself
when I was homeless
and your kids are aware
I don't know
I say that because um
after that relationship
you stopped talking to me
for two years because I found out he was
with my cousin so I couldn't lose
I didn't contact him for two years well
in that two years I met my husband
Sammy Lee Martinez
hit it off great and everything and
and um
I didn't even know we were having
problems
I was looking for five years we had got
married we were homeless the whole time
you know he took me out on the street
and he abandoned me at the street
and um
come to find out
my marriage was a lie
he's been embezzling me the whole time
he found out about an inheritance I was
getting
and he embezzled me along with the same
girl that took my other fiancee
and um
it got a hold of my um I heard my kids
screaming one day and when I was
homeless I heard him screaming and
screaming screaming screaming when going
this way one going that way one way this
one which way do I go which way you go
crying crying crying crying crying they
tried to kill me
and
um
should I shoot me in the head with a
shotgun
I got my child and I left
after that um
can be silly
after everything was fine
come to my surprise
things wasn't
as good as I thought
he's a liar
conniver
I don't know who he is
and I really don't care to this point
he um
you raped my daughter
he had me handcuffed and drugged
tortured
I would go missing periodically
and um
I was left for dead
they drowned me
and then the office my father's my
inheritance
my father's a state
and um
I didn't even know anything until I
started getting my memory back
I don't know what he was giving me I
didn't even know every time I slept
he drugged me
people were telling me I seen you
running the street naked like no
oh let me not me
me it was me
um I have markings all over my body
he broke my knees backwards
my eye was hanging
I had 11 children
one was still on the umbilical cord
dragging behind me
and nail sticking out of my head
and my skin was really hanging
hanging on me
like you know because
that's what my skin was I got scars all
up and down
um
I was unaware of all this
oh me and my daughter were passed out
everybody
he paid to have us raped
as he watched
[Music]
and uh the girl
is family member
they too were involved
both sides of my family
they tortured my family my immediate
family my children and their children
um
they lied to everybody
saying that I killed their kids she
killed her kids
audio started coming out some way
somehow
I was pushing record on my phone
and I caught what I needed to catch
um
everything she's this cool guy because
he's passing out money this is nice the
rich guy now and all this all my cousins
are involved they're females
I hired protection the job got done
perfectly until he stepped in
in back again in the tortures
that's why I don't know where my kids
are
Nicole Joseph and Michael
Russell Rudy
Angie
Myra
elenise and Michael how many kids do you
have
I have
14. they were pulling babies out of me I
was unaware
until I heard audio
I'm pregnant I'm having a baby I'm
having a baby you know I'm just really
audio
I wish I could present it to you but I
don't have it you know I just came
unprepared
and um I got all the evidence to back up
my story
I try to go to the police department
no help
drugs are a part of your story
no it is drugs are in fact part of my
story because I relapsed
and nothing else to lean on my friends
were turning their backs on me
nobody was being my friend I couldn't
understand why
because they were lying to them
and I have a lot of friends
and now I can't um I can't I have no one
faithful
that would just come into my house and
be my friend
I've asked have you seen my daughter out
there is my daughter out there my
daughter out there no no no no no no no
but I know they're lying I could hear it
you know
my kids are getting beat as we speak
probably
I'm still getting beat when I go to
sleep
and this was a joke I have to be
drugged up to be wired up so I won't
sleep because instead of a [__] comes
in my room
she rapes me
every time
until today
it was last week when he did it
my daughter was also raped tied to a
tree well I was being drowned
I was 10 hours and 59 minutes away from
death
let me open up when I was under that
water
all I could do was pray
pray
47 minutes underwater
thank you Lord
also did anybody no you have no no
family no kids
I don't know where they're at
even some of the communities
people in the community are missing
I always have to check to see you if
somebody's still there because
they go missing are you killed or get
tortured
true Factor my friend got thrown off a
building five stories high
but almost everybody in his body
there was no reason for that
everybody I talk to they go right behind
me and talk to that person
what's it trying to get I don't know
leave them alone you know leave my
friends alone these people who I talk to
them I mean this girl Beatrice she's my
cousin
and she left with
my husband and they get more orgy and
that's all he does
I don't know I walked back with him the
other day he's supposed to be dead
he died six eleven twenty one but I was
in back of him walking right in back of
him
so I called him dead man walking
doesn't seem like I'm afraid I like I
don't care but I do
what more could I do I've gone to the
police
they block my phone
you're ripping me off I'm trying to get
out of my residence
everybody's just ripping me up
everybody's looking me off
everybody talks about me
I'm really tired of it
and um
I didn't do nothing to them
I like I said I didn't even know I was
having problems
I had his mother up
paying his mother to go find my father's
will because I knew there was money
there
and um
he got it he gave it to my cousins
so he could get
pushed
alrighty
they killed his ex-girlfriend as well
they went on a killing spree
they shot a son in the face and he's
still with them
I don't get it
um
it was a nightmare
are you supporting yourself now I get
Social Security
I've been giving it getting it for a
while like 2007.
and um I found a place for 500 so thank
God I got on my feet by myself
what is the drug that you're playing
around with Christopher
um well I smoke
and I used to shoot up for three years
but
that wasn't me you know who's to say
that I was um that's opiates this this
at my age you know what I mean my age I
should be shooting up heroin heroin yeah
and uh
I'm getting off heroin now
but that that run was um
awful awful
you're smoking crystal meth absolutely
crystal meth well my husband um
introduced me to it he taught me how to
smoke now I know why because um he got
me on drugged up so uh he'd go to the
courts and tell the courts that hey
she's all on drugs and this is that her
and him and my brother my little brother
I have another brother like
different mother
and him he's involved and uh
because we're all living happy go lucky
well me and my kids and my immediate
family being tortured today
I mean we get passed around
I have a video of me being dragged in
the lobby of the King Edwards
and guess what I know I'm a landowner
and um I struck oil
they took that
I want to Publishers Clearing House they
checked that
they're wiping me off the database so I
don't exist and I don't know how to stop
them anymore
um
uh my father left me and my grandfather
very very
wealthy
and um but I struggled today
because um
they acting like me and everybody and
anybody's suing me
people are lying to me
people come in my room
when I'm asleep
people's like right now I'm over here
giving this interview and somebody's
probably in my room right this minute
eating my food probably raping my son
but maybe my daughter they're trying to
take bone marrow
my little kids are so [__] thin
they're feeding of oatmeal with his
quick drinks he met
and they make sure that I hear
everything
you know it's his ex-girlfriend her name
is henya they call her
and she thinks she's this big old um
madam
that mother she gave her kids away she
wants to be a matter
of kids
she was also involved because she wanted
child support
I mean everybody's just taking
everything and just handing everything
out making sure I don't get anything
didn't want to take my social security
didn't divert my mail I don't get no
calls I don't get no letters I get
nothing
do you have anybody that's that you can
trust
no
that's what they say I know you needed
the money
winning everything
they want to make sure I'm alone that my
kids pass away too
I don't know what who has its Vengeance
on me to do this I don't know why
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned from all of this
yeah there's no listen
there wasn't no listen it was just
an awful man that I never even knew
he had other people acting like him with
the same features everything
I noticed he was getting shorter and
shorter
I moved out over he's done it it came to
downtown at the Mayfair
I went in my room and he was there
I get on my side of the bed and the
closet's like straight ahead and make
them I'm getting ready to lay down isn't
it [__] jumping come out of the
closet
I see the person who it was
all I could do was close my eyes
and I woke up
I don't know what happened after that I
was too scared to open my eyes
we got a lot of raping has been going on
people are dying
everything's oh they're taking the money
that's just no it's not just about the
money it's about people's lives
oh because one family member was jealous
that she thought she could be me better
than me
I don't even know how to beat me
so that's why I use
I think that uses comfort
so I'm gonna cry you know it numbs me
yeah oh but that's all she doesn't say
no but what do you do I believe there's
cameras in my room
this is horrible this is a nightmare I
can't wake up I'm trying to kiss
there's cops missing
Social Services
associate workers missing
my friend got thrown out of a 37 story
window
another girlfriend she got thrown over a
12-story window
you know I hear my head and sing okay
the better offer
the better offer he's happy where he is
now
[Music]
he's married
has the kids
very happily ever after being famous out
there
and I'm just this prostitute
drug addict
I have the audios
wish I would have brought him
could you trust me
I understand why everybody hates me
right now because of the money I mean we
got the money they have it and they
still
hurt me
I have two holes right here
two two six inch nails
I had five babies tied to me because I
didn't want to lose them I was living in
the dark
I don't know where but I was in the dark
thank you
[Music]
my friend found me
he nurtured me
he
broke my legs back right
Slow Me Up
um he stepped on my eyeball
but it was a good thing because when he
stepped on it
it's hanging
when he stepped on it
it got caught to a night vision lens
I would see in the dark
like kid you not I used to throw it so
far the demand there's a toy to see
who's coming over there they used to
come I don't know I could hear him
coming I don't know how I where I was I
don't know I can hear it coming so he's
trying to hide because it was pitch
black but they had those goggles on
you just have to hide from them you know
but we get to walls and I don't know and
I would still get raped down there
they tortured me they put me through an
electric shock
they stretched me
they
they come in here here
um
I didn't brush my teeth but over a year
I ate [__] from his [__]
straight from his [__]
I have fake teeth because um
when they started happening I took them
off
because I didn't want them to get messed
up so I hit them
I was bald
um
he used to beat me up left and right
bowling balls you just drop on my head
this man hated me
and I didn't even know we're having
problems
um
and and he is also a drug user he's an
IV user
um
and the whole relationship
actually the whole 10 years
they've been doing this to me and I
wasn't aware
and then when I ordered the protection
it stopped and my husband got involved
and it started again
so
yeah
I have an audio of the whole
relationship
and um
he's king of the world right now
Satan
and you're here on the streets
at the King Edward
be careful out there
he's good looking guys so be careful
all right you guys see my daughter I
mean any of my kids I'm offering Rewards
I haven't seen him in three years four
years
they're being prostituted
they say collateral collateral they
don't even know what the meaning is
so my mother's out there too she's 84.
she's also prostituted
I can't find my family
Martinez
whatever your name is today
go to hell [__] you and I'm coming for
you
[__] the money
I want you in jail you and your entrance
that's all I had to say all right Cindy
Lou thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you